The edge springs are used to ensure
that your edge stitches knit correctly.
Although knitters say that they've
successfully knit without using them,
to prevent misformed stitches and possible
jamming, it's best to get in the habit
of positioning them while you're knitting.
The edge spring has a rounded ridge
that fits into the rounded
slot on the needle bed.
The edge spring slips along the needle bed
and is aligned with the outer
edge needles the knitting.
The latch of the edge
needle must be closed.
The best way to ensure this is
to position the edge spring.
Push the latch needle out so
the latch moves past the edge spring.
Pull the needle back and the edge spring
will close the latch automatically.
Position the needle with the edge of the
needle channel and you're ready to knit.